foreign
starts off this hour in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Liz how are you
I'm good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call so I am beast
in North Carolina
um and I make 43 000 a year I'm on baby
step two paying off debt I just cut up
my first credit card which was a
whirlwind but got through that and now I
have twenty thousand dollars in debt and
student loans to the government and I
had two questions kind of revolving that
one should I wait to pay it off for like
wait for it to get forgiven or should I
start paying it off now and the second
one kind of comes in with that my dad
passed a few years ago and left an
inheritance I have literally the exact
change amount to pay that off
um I've been hesitant to do that because
I kind of want to feel my own pain of my
own stupid decision but I also don't
want to put that money towards my loans
I'd rather do something more important
with it
um so yeah that's my kind of question
cool is that your only debt twenty
thousand dollars for student loans yes I
thought you said you cut up a credit
card no doubt on it yes yeah no I always
paid off my my limit but George came
will help me figure out okay I need to
cut it up I did look at that who knew
Dave that's awesome to hear Liz so if
this is the only debt and you said The
Inheritance is to the penny the amount
now I don't know what your faith
background is you know you can call it a
coincidence but that just seems pretty
happenstance
that the inheritance matches up to your
debt
it is and I I've thought a lot about it
and it just and my dad was very like
very financially
um I mean he came in he came over from
Venezuela and he
um had a very difficult life um
providing for himself in the family so
he was on track like trying to do he
didn't agree with Dave all together but
I started on the Dave train a little
while ago but
um he really wanted me to own a home and
really wanted me to get like financially
um supported supporting myself so I just
I don't know if I'm crazy for using that
money or if I'm like I I also don't want
to not feel the pain of my own decision
yeah
um
uh
your dad I'm gonna guess
was a person of great integrity
yes
yeah he was and so you paying off a loan
that you signed your name to and
borrowed
even if it later might be paid off by
the government is an act of Integrity
that I think he would be proud of
yeah yeah I know yeah and I think if
that and I think if you use your
inheritance for that I don't think he
would call you stupid and neither would
I
um and I don't think you have to get 30
lashes on your back just to prove that
you learned a lesson
I I think you've learned your lesson I
hope you've learned your lesson are you
going to go borrow money again
no no no okay if you're through then
you're through right and so you know
let's use this and get cleaned up and
then build your emergency fund and then
let's start Building Wealth so that you
can leave it uh to your heirs and have
the same kind of Legacy that your dad
had
yeah I
told them this plan of hanging off and
they all looked at me like I was crazy
and they they ripped me to shreds and I
said no but this is about integrity so I
I thank you for your advice yeah yeah I
I just I think one of the things I
always think about when someone asked me
um what they should do with an
inheritance that they got is always
think about the person that left the
inheritance and what would make them
smile from heaven
and I don't think you paying off your
debts now that you've learned your
lesson and you living a financially
responsible life going forward
regardless of if some half-butt family
member ripped you to shreds or not
um
you know uh
you just you know I'm just going to pay
off a debt that I actually owe
and not wait on uh welfare and
um I I got a feeling your dad's smiling
about that
um and so uh and here's the other thing
five years from today
if you live forward following the Ramsey
process continuing in the baby steps
you're going to have substantial money
and five years from today are you going
to look back if the debts are forgiven
by uh the government later are you going
to look back and feel like you did
something wrong
no you're not
so you're not going to have regret long
term from having done the right thing
even if it even if it has a little bit
of pain to it and even if uh stupid
people disagree with you stupid people
disagree with you all the time when it
comes to money that's why we call them
stupid people they don't get a vote
you're not taking a poll and so you
raised the question earlier Liz of what
if there's more important things I
should be doing with this money and I
can think of nothing more important than
setting yourself free financially from
this debt that's been hanging over your
neck and if they forgive if the bind
Administration gets it through the
courts and next week they come out and
forgive it which they're not going to
but I I personally wouldn't have any
regret because I signed up for this trip
and I took the trip you know this this
decision is taking up too much mental
space when it could be free right now
too many calories